yeah but if you imagine like
I've never heard the sentence doesn't
that's a baby
[Music]
and welcome to a special edition of JK
news today we have Hannah in the hot
seat everybody put your hands together
[Applause]
get the UK it's been a long time coming
dude this is this is a big deal that
you're here
it is and if I had to choose
I'm gonna [__] my mom
why would you like your mom holy [__]
it's the Bart's cold oh Christ she's
oh my God [__] your mom these Brits are
smart I mean she's had four kids she
probably wouldn't notice oh true
sorry Mom is there a [__]
ing dude
we gotta rewind a little bit because
Bart still needs to to send it off with
a cold that's the hottest star ever that
was amazing sorry Mom
she's a wonderful woman actually yeah I
think she would be actually a wonderful
she's very nurturing yeah so I can
imagine she would like ease me through
it like don't worry about it Hannah we
have to do this and I think
I think we could turn it into a bonding
moment I think it would actually make us
stronger as a mother and daughter it'd
make you guys good only fan star that's
what I'll say especially because we're
both Ginger oh sure and Kazumi's doing
mom action content too and it's making a
lot of money mom actually yep
pretty cool oh man we need to chill it
down a bit that is the most married guy
reaction today yeah yeah I love action
huh that being said yeah we uh normally
started off way less fun uh because we
try to delete our subscribers right away
but we're gonna go back into that
terrible formula we're gonna have Bart
start with a colder question and uh this
is where people click away as Steve
Green says
can you sing Happy Birthday in a
Vietnamese accent
[Laughter]
American accent dude you don't want to
hear myself
what's worse the first two lines
or how many lines you should get a jaw
already I feel my ancestors just like
dying
happy birthday no it's not even right
it's added more British than usual
you're good at copying Valley girls
though okay to the valley girl one happy
birthday just just lean into it a little
bit more yeah
[Music]
that's Vietnamese
that's what you all sound like to me
like just nasal yeah just nasal I can't
breathe out of my nose oh really
oh [__] you don't win many fights you
don't watch the show then oh you don't
know my [__] I don't watch it that much
if you try to sing Happy Birthday and it
came out happy birthday happy birthday
she sounds like a speaking spell like
wait what the [__] it's been good oh my
God okay where are we at oh yeah it's a
hot seat let's ask some real hot
questions let's get it going y'all Nick
go ahead start off make it juicy come on
where did you meet Joe
oh I really want to know Instagram yeah
where did you guys where did you guys
meet in person for the first time
y'all Airbnb right
that's so sexy yeah I came from work and
he was waiting outside for me
and then we went upstairs I threw her in
the [__] shower and we [__] yeah he
made me shower do you think that's rude
wait he made you yeah wait you guys
[__] in the first place in the first
five minutes we did that thing where you
like oh I'll give you a tour but like
you know he's like oh yeah yeah I
[__] Leonidas kicked their butt into
the bathtub
yeah he made me shower that's [__] I
didn't make you do nothing wait this is
her Hot Seat man yeah I'm not sure where
the story is but I'm gonna believe the
hot seat you should yeah I walked in he
was like that's Josh I was like hey Josh
he's like this is the kitchen I was like
oh that's nice this is you know the
bedroom I was like oh lovely bedroom and
that's my dick yeah basically was he
like and this is the shower see if it
works
he was like I don't want to be rude but
I didn't say crap I didn't say that that
sounds like you bro we actually got in
the shower together and then you know
what and then you know what
um I was jet lagged and I was hungry
and yes he was was it grumpy way so he
ate
we went to Italian food
yeah we did I didn't want to go I was
like quite happy just to say and he was
like no I'm hungry so he made us get out
of bed maybe put clothes on
man he's making you alive how Okay do we
need to maybe slow down a little bit how
did you got you guys didn't go like all
right this is my name hi this is my name
oh yes we did yeah or did you guys build
up over a text or like did the
relationship build to shoot yeah we were
like messaging
casual chat in Utah no sexy messaging at
all no and then one day we were talking
and we were saying that it would be
really interesting to like write an
erotic fiction but half from the men's
point of view and then the other woman's
point of view so like it's the same
story who brought that idea at first oh
100 me because I want to write erotic
fiction oh oh tonight yeah so I was
saying it'd be really interesting to do
like the same story but the woman tells
it and then the man tells it and then we
were that little until we should just
[__] are we allowed to [__] spend 30
seconds uh we should just [__] and then
both write the story and then that led
into just sexting and then little did
you know the years would turn out to be
hentai
when it comes to my version It's just
straight porn I do look like
Alexa
um I mean pale works but yeah I didn't
know what she looked like he didn't to
be fat he could have been talking to a
guy at this point he didn't know my name
and he didn't know what I looked like he
was just sexting is that what he wanted
oh it's her story by the time I was
sexting you I already knew what I look
you looked nope he didn't yes I did you
gotta wait no you gotta wait till the
end you gotta wait till the end for any
uh rebuttal yeah write down your notes
if you want to go back to those fine
this is her time because at this point
Fox purely text messages no and then
maybe the odd photo but that could have
been catfishing yeah he doesn't really
knowing no we had a video called we
hadn't spoken when you say like the odd
photo like what kind of photo you were
talking about
no he would send that yeah overruled
overruled overruled I could have been
catfishing you 100 no you didn't have
their Instagram
but there was no like selfies or
anything like that on it oh no
memory so who reached out to who no no I
got a better question uh Ginger goldfish
just shut down my question dude that's a
bad question first time having sex okay
with Joe you guys just met within five
minutes you guys are [__] obviously
you have zero expectations yeah so when
you guys first do it yeah what was the
first thing that made an impression or
good or bad that good or bad was the
impression or I was like that's
interesting what was the first thing I
I'm saying this genuinely and not
because I love him yeah the most
handsome penis I've ever seen in my life
oh yeah
let's take a look Joe Joe you're
supposed to say no
[Laughter]
let me show them there's blushes
blushy dude
[Laughter]
get it up get it out get it out no yeah
let me see let me hold it let me hold it
no no you really love me so you saw it
describe it you saw it and you're like
and you're like wow yeah because it's
it's hard we've got a pen and paper
oh it's a smiley face
yeah draw a piece of tape
he's got paper he's got paper oh we got
paper
damn like 50 pages
just write the number four and we'll get
it wait Did you see it hard or soft it
was hard I was in the room it's fine
she designs
you can't say anything yeah dude this is
her Hot Seat man it's bigger than that
it's not to scale
no that's too small
she said birthday guy
she didn't say the size she said it was
handsome
Tom Cruise is handsome but he's not big
he's impressed you see those eyes look
at those expressive eyes look at the
accuracy of how one ball holds longer
than the other really a little bit Yeah
but I don't mind that because it's like
I think you know nothing nothing perfect
is really beautiful absolutely it's the
floors that really created oh is this
supposed to be like one lower anyway she
made it half like so small no it smells
small I think we all got that all right
so this is actual size
what I really enjoy about it that you'll
notice is the symmetry of the cylinder
so all the way up that's a two inch dig
baby uh maybe you've got a lovely sized
penis wait so your first view of it was
from underneath yeah
just in case you're not share of scale
this is the iPhone 13 Pro Max
[Music]
on the scale iPhone 13 Pro Max let me
let me
yeah but if you imagine like
I've never heard the sentence that's a
two inch baby
who's ever said that no what kind of
situation is that
between the arrows that's my hand wow
okay okay that's good so okay happy and
it can't be inaccurate notice
immediately about his penis was it was
completely symmetrical top to bottom wow
and then also the proportion of the
helmet area also the girth of the actual
shaft there's no bin it was it was
honestly there really is no Bend no Bend
and honestly the color from top to
bottom the same color no way I have oh
wait I have what's called a bonsai dick
what does that mean what the [__] is
that I shaped it like I shaved it as I
was growing like you know how this is
going you just you know how they have
the they boxed the kitties or whatever
and they shape the thing it's a it's a
culture box the kitties yeah I think we
should make dildos
that's amazing yeah that's what I know
that's a two-ish deal though make him
wear it so we see how it looks on him
yeah maybe we can cut this one out and
then like they put it to scale like just
stand up bro stand up stand up oh that's
sad yeah just fold it right there there
you go
it's a perfect heart it looks like a key
underneath it is like a lovely heart wow
oh wow it's really nice it was a really
lovely penis it's got a real winter joke
oh my gosh not a drop of Smeg not a drop
very clean real clean day yeah we did
shower before though
but I have a lot of pre-cum though what
do you mean like all the time yeah
I drool a lot just do not from my mouth
I got a question yeah it's getting
really hot yeah I'm like Jesus what does
Joe do
that pisses you off
pisses me off yeah
let me put this on so I can hear [__]
[__] where the foot did you get that
two things come to mind okay one he
doesn't let me eat in bed which I think
is disgusting Behavior he doesn't let
you eat no it doesn't let me shut up
shut the [__] up
this is my time to talk okay it doesn't
let me eat in bed on what grounds what
does he say the reason is why you
shouldn't do it
I mean it's logical it's because he
doesn't like bits in the bed what kind
of stuff do you want to eat in bed wait
so you sleep in bed Nando's you eat some
nandos yeah
anything in bed in bed he doesn't like
wait you would like so you like having
[__] crumbs and [__] and then
sleeping
I'll still be able to smell it I like to
have a bit of sauce you know it's a
midnight snack she wants to dust her
mouth lemon and lemon and Herb sheets
and almond croissant in bed yeah I'll
not be lovely
a nightmare too you said two this
doesn't annoy me anymore because I've
learned to use it to my advantage oh but
what he does sometimes having
conversations with him is like it's not
a phone call it's a text message
so you'll say something to him and it
registers and you'll get an answer in
like 10 minutes yeah that's about right
because he's clocked it in he's just not
replied to it yet what do you mean wait
she's verbal yeah so like you know how
you have a phone call and you get like
immediate yeah his work's more like a
text message it goes to a queue yeah
kind of like he he registers it it's
buffering so you ask him hey do you need
anything from the supermarket he's just
telling you about his day and then a 10
minutes later he's like can you bring
some toast please yes uh why it's useful
is because you can just brain dump and
he absorbs it all and then just through
the day you get answers but very
thoughtful ones though right yeah and he
he thinks it through and it comes at
random points too is it usually in like
a feudal Japan story that it comes back
in because that's what we get maybe like
you'll be having a [__] or something
he'll open the door and be like and then
just respond something you said like two
days ago having a [__] it's useful
because you can just brain dump it yeah
and then eventually you'll get the
response
I know what the combinations of the lock
is yeah yeah so you just got to learn
how to use it at first I was confused
because I was like is he just not
listening to me because he's not
responding but he's looking me in the
eye you know what I mean yeah and then
like two days later I'm like okay I see
how this works uh that's good that
you've adjusted to it I'll wear the uh
14 a minute and 54 seconds part where
you know we turn up the heat a little
bit Joe don't say anything just okay uh
have you ever talked about uh children
with this thing oh this thing yeah yeah
probably gonna have like four probably
gonna have four yeah whoa I got pot and
come do you have enough pre-cum for that
he has potent cover that's more than
enough
are there things in terms of like a a
future life concept together where like
yeah maybe you guys have had
disagreements or haven't come to an
understanding yet
no I think we're both just curious
people so we're kind of up for anything
the the end goal for me is we have a
castle probably in Scotland or Wales
we're Lord and Lady like I want it
officially on our passports wow how do
you do that he's looking up castles in
Japan right now for 39 000.
I've got multiple yeah and then just
bunch of kids
yeah but we're not really looking after
them like we're giving to my parents
yeah yeah I told you she wants the bad
and kids like me yeah I think that's the
best if we like them Hawaii if we don't
England
put them in the cold old boarding school
cool something like that but yeah like
four kids because he needs to repopulate
Japan you know yeah yeah that's true
it's a real issue yeah but you're just
not sending them there
it solves the problem
the economy still takes what do you
think uh Joe loves about you the most
um it's hard to choose huh
all right you're giving her no time
um
did I eat anything I think that was
mostly the compliment he gives me that's
funny because you started off vegetarian
you just broke me I think what he likes
about me is the things that he's changed
about me oh he takes credit for those
he's trying to save you you know yeah
he's got to say you know what's funny is
David was saying like you've been so
deprived of flavors for so long that now
every single food he likes watching her
eat because she looks like she's
enjoying it for the first time because
she really is and David lives through
your experience yeah if it's a feta yeah
oh yeah he is he loves to eat but back
to Joe what have you discovered is Joe's
favorite kink
I'll probably be our stuff but I think
everyone knows that right yeah I mean
even my mum knows that because she heard
and talk about it in a video it depends
what that means for me like his ass or
your ass both oh both I guess but I'm
not as into it as he is oh I just wanted
to pretend like she likes it yeah he
just likes a little bum lick yeah
it's nothing like
guy actually in bed
just like sex very Japanese of Emma I
know
little bum lick that's pretty hardcore
really yeah for a lot of people they're
squeamish
who it's an ass in the room
[Laughter]
that's a good question who's licking ass
in this room I have like ass yeah I mean
I gotta you kind of even on accident
it'll happen oh yeah because you're just
like playing around in the area
I don't like my ass getting lit oh
really definitely not why not it's shame
probably yeah you just feel bad it
tickles mine's ticklish and shy yeah
Catholic
no I might have Catholic sensibilities I
think you do are you Catholic do you
what's what's your religious upbringing
and or religion right now
uh religious upbringing is
pretty unusual for the UK we were pretty
religious Christian when I was a kid
one Grandad was a pastor one was a
reverend so we were like pretty hardcore
yeah but I have no sexual shame so I
don't really understand what your
problem is well I just you know it's not
shame necessarily it's just more like um
you know poop comes out of my butt and I
just don't wanna
yeah all the time ever since they showed
it to me I can't stop watching it
um no but I just don't want anyone I
don't want my my wife's mouth near my
butt dude that's crazy what if it's just
your homies that's cool you want a
homie's mouth
what's the most I want her mouth on
everything if I could she's just this is
the most romantic thing yeah that Joe's
having done for you
romantic he's actually very romantic see
let me tell you something what yeah yeah
her hot seat thank you
I taught him to be romantic he didn't
believe me oh really yeah I'm not
allowing you to take credit for that so
let's name an example uh give us an
example where he was romantic he parked
in the shade so I didn't get sunburned
yup I think that's romantic that is
romantic he's very considerate very
considerate he's very thoughtful like he
tries to think of like nice things to do
one time I tell you what he did we drove
up a mountain with a picnic and we
watched the sunset in the back of the
car wait I'm starting not to believe
this though because
your advice to Anthony for Valentine's
Day was the complete opposite of what
she's doing are you lying to our fans
it's about your personality it's not
because when did I do that was it a
special day I don't remember there you
go it was surprised she's like it was
March 14th oh [__] oh [__] every big
day's on the 14th of every month I have
a question for you oh Joe's got a
question I got a question for you yeah
all right
what did I get you for Christmas
these shoes I just took your card no
that's not a real present
I was telling him
a few more things too yeah I mean if
we're actually I actually got a few I
got a few bits um
the element of surprise yeah she
probably bought a bunch of stuff that
I'm unaware of but she she asks me even
though she doesn't need to but then
the thing is she got me a paddle board
it was very thoughtful I didn't do a
damn thoughtful thing
ever and then but then she still keeps
calling me romantic so I'm like I could
just be myself and I'm lucky
that's beautiful that's cute you're
romantic Joe you're like Joe Nancy but I
don't ever do it on the days that I'm
supposed to do it that's better though
because if you're just doing it when you
have to do it that's not romantic
surprise that's true have you had an
argument that you haven't been able to
resolve yet
like how he wants all of your children
to be Seventh-Day Adventists
okay but not on a Celtic seventh day
but I argument we haven't resolved other
than the eating in bed thing that's the
biggest one it really annoys me I'm not
gonna lie you really are still fighting
I mean we fight though we fought
yesterday yeah but I can't remember why
no but you're lecturing me on the plane
and I'll send her like all [__] up
lecturing on the plane yeah I
I but then after
a couple hangry fighting and then after
they eat they're like cool kid and we're
like laughing about it like that that
was us but that was I thought I thought
he was being too hard on himself uh well
she was lecturing me about how I thought
about myself yeah but we were fighting
about it because I was like you're a
good person
meanwhile someone in the middle seat's
like guys hurry up
regardless of Joe just for yourself
what's something that you hope uh to
accomplish in life
brexit too
you guys should have asked her more
about her because it's talking about uh
just said regardless of Joe we have to
do a part to me I swear to God every
yeah what do you do part two you guys
talk about me too much it's just the
dynamic is too powerful we gotta ask you
know but part two is coming up for sure
I don't know if I have like a specific
like one goal there's a lot of
collective things
not I just don't want to have a boring
life that's my biggest fear it's just
looking back and being like that was
[__] boring I feel that can I tell
you guys something she has a very
exciting life and you should talk more
about her instead of us
and you know we'll just have to save it
for part two guys for sure this war is a
part two
[__] that's so funny